IF THAT’S THE FOCUS OF TONIGHT’S
ANGLE.
OF DONALD TRUMP NEVER GOT THE
CHANCE TO BREATHE AS PRESIDENT.
DEMOCRATS DEEP STATORS AND TRUMP
GRIFTERS ALL PLAYED A ROLE IN
THIS NEFARIOUS EFFORT.
THEY DID EVERYTHING THEY COULD
TO DRIVE HIM OUT OF OFFICE LONG
BEFORE HE WAS SWORN IN.
IT THEY ILLEGALLY SURVEYED HIS
CAMPAIGN, FORCED THEM TO SPEND
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS IN LEGAL
FEES, THIRD AND HIS FAMILY,
DRAGGED OUT THE RIDICULOUS
MUELLER INVESTIGATION, IMPEACHED
HIM FOR TALKING TO THE PRESIDENT
OF THE UKRAINE, AND WHEN ALL
THAT FIELD, THEY MOVED ON TO
BLAMING HIM FOR COVID.
THEN FOR THE RIGHTS AFTER GEORGE
FLOYD’S DEATH.
EVERY STEP OF THE WAY, THE SMALL
MINDED MEN AND WOMEN WHO MAKE UP
THE AMERICAN LEFT AND TO BE
AMERICAN PRESS CORPS WERE
COMPLICIT.
>> DONALD TRUMP IS A CRIMINAL
ENTERPRISE.
>> A PRESIDENCY IN PERIL, AS WE
LEARN MORE ABOUT THE MUELLER
INVESTIGATION, THE WALLS ARE
CLOSING IN ON PRESIDENT TRUMP
AND TASTE IN HER CIRCLE.
>> DONALD TRUMP I MISS HANDLING
COVID SO BADLY HAS BRANDED
HIMSELF AS INCOMPETENT.
>> THIS IS NOT THE FIRST TIME
DONALD TRUMP HAS FALLEN SHORT OF
BEING A LEADER.
HE IS ROUTINELY CALLED FOR
VIOLENCE IN THIS COUNTRY.
IT >> Laura: THAT ONE THAT WAS
PAINFUL TO WATCH.
HE PICKED THEM AS FAKE NEWS,
DIDN’T HE?
HE REFUSED TO SUCK UP TO THEM
LIKE SO MANY OTHER POLITICIANS.
AT SOME POINT ALONG THE WAY,
REPORTERS AND PRODUCERS WHO
WANTS KIND OF WHERE
SEMIREASONABLE JUST BECAME
COMPLETE AND UTTER PARTISAN
HACKS.
THEIR PLAYBOOK CONSISTED OF
DOWNPLAYING OR IGNORING TRUMPS
MANY ACHIEVEMENTS AND TYPING
BASELESS ALLEGATIONS WITHOUT ANY
OBJECTIVE CORROBORATION AGAINST
HIM.
THEN BY THE FALL, DEMOCRATS ON
THE HILL AND IN NEWSROOMS ACROSS
THE COUNTRY HAD AN URGENT
CLEANUP OPERATION ON THEIR
HANDS.
AT THAT POINT, THEY BEGAN TO
ENGAGE IN A MASSIVE COVER-UP FOR
JOE BIDEN’S FAMILY, WHICH HAD
PROFITED A COURSE INSTANTLY FROM
THE SUN HUNTERS UNUSUAL BUSINESS
DEALINGS ABROAD.
A COMPUTER STORE OWNER WHO HAD
POSSESSION OF HIS LAPTOP CAME
FORWARD AND EMAILS BEGIN TO LEAK
OUT.
AFTER "THE NEW YORK POST" BROKE
THE STORY AND BEGAN PUBLISHING
HUNTERS EMAILS, ONLY A FEW MAJOR
OUTLETS LIKE FOX TOOK IT ALL
SERIOUSLY.
TURNS OUT ACTUAL DOLLAR FIGURES
FOR THE CHINESE CONSULTANCY HAD
BEEN DISCUSSED, APPARENTLY WITH
HIS FATHER’S LESSON.
IF ONE EMAIL MENTIONED A
SPECIFIC DOLLAR AMOUNT SET ASIDE
FOR THE BIG GUY WHO IS WIDELY
THOUGHT TO BE JOE BIDEN HIMSELF.
WELL, THIS IS WHEN THE BIDEN
CAMPAIGN SURROGATES BEGAN
CIRCLING THE WAGON.
GOAT APPEARED IN THE TABLOID
THAT PRESIDENT TRUMP AND HIS
ALLIES ARE TRYING TO SEIZE ON
THIS.
>> IT’S A SERIES OF BUZZ WORDS
THAT HAVE MEANING PERHAPS IF
YOU’VE BEEN STUDYING DAILY COLOR
OR WHATEVER IT IS.
IT’S BECAUSE THIS IS AN EXAMPLE
OF STEVE BANNON GIVING A TIP TO
A "NEW YORK POST" REPORTER, RUDY
GIULIANI HANDING OVER A BUNCH OF
DOCUMENTS AND FOX RUNNING WITH
IT FOR DAYS ON END CREATING AN
APPEARANCE OF A SCANDAL
INVOLVING HUNTER BIDEN.
>> Laura: ARE THEY THAT ON
SELF-AWARE.
IT CREATING THE APPEARANCE OF A
SCANDAL QUESTION MIKE THAT’S ALL
THEY TRIED TO DO FOR FOUR YEARS
AGAINST PRESIDENT TRUMP.
WE NOW KNOW THIS WAS ALL A LIE.
THEY KNEW THAT HUNTER WAS A
SLEAZEBAG TRYING TO PROFIT OFF
OF HIS FATHER’S HIGH-POWERED
POSITION.
IF THEY THESE EMAILS PUT
JOE BIDEN’S CANDIDACY AT RISK IN
A CLOSE ELECTION.
IF THE ROLES WERE REVERSED, ALL
OF THESE MEDIA MARBLES WOULD’VE
LEFT NO STONE UNTURNED TO HOLD
TRUMP ACCOUNTABLE.
OF COURSE THE MEDIA AND THEIR
DEMOCRATIC COLLEAGUES HAD TO
THROW SAND IN YOUR EYES SO YOU
WOULDN’T EVEN SEE THE STORY.
THEY DIDN’T COVER IT AT ALL OR
THEY WENT TO THEIR TRUMP ERA
DEFAULT MODE, THEY BLAMED RUSSIA
RUSSIA.
>> THIS WHOLE SMEAR ON JOE BIDEN
COMES FROM THE KREMLIN.
>> EVERY INTELLIGENCE
PROFESSIONAL I’VE TALKED TO SAYS
THIS IS A RUSSIAN INTELLIGENCE
DISINFORMATION CAMPAIGN.
>> IT COULD’VE COME FROM RUSSIAN
MILITARY HACKING OF UKRAINIAN
GAS COMPANY WHERE HUNTER BIDEN
SERVED.
>> RUDY GIULIANI WAS DEALING
WITH ALLEGED RUSSIAN
INTELLIGENCE AGENT.
>> RUDY GIULIANI IS A RUSSIAN
ASSET AT THIS POINT.
BECAUSE THIS IS WHAT THEY ARE
DOING, GRASPING AT STRAWS.
IN CASE THAT DIDN’T WORK TO KEEP
THE SCANDAL AT BAY, THEY HAD TO
INJECT COVID INTO THE BIDEN
STORY AND ATTEMPT TO KILL IT.
>> TRUMP IS SPENDING THE WEEK
TRYING TO MAKE HUNTER BIDEN A
THING DOWNPLAYING COVID.
>> THE PRESIDENT IS GOING TO
TAKE ADVICE ON COVID-19, WHICH
IS WHY THEY ARE BRINGING IN SOME
OF THESE OTHER TOPICS LIKE
HUNTER BIDEN.
TO SPEAK OF THE TRUTH IS, WHERE
IN THE MIDDLE OF A PANDEMIC.
INSTEAD OF DEBATING CROWDS ODDS
OR CONSPIRACY THEORIES, WE
SHOULD BE TALKING ABOUT POLICY,
VALUES, AND IDEAS.
>> Laura: OKAY.
AGAIN, IT WAS PUBLICLY REPORTED
THAT BIDEN’S LAPTOP HAD BEEN
SEIZED BY THE FBI BACK IN 2019.
IT DIDN’T TAKE A LEGAL SAVANT TO
KNOW THAT THIS IS A BIG DEAL.
IT’S WHEN THEY SHOULD’VE STARTED
TO ASK A LOT OF QUESTIONS.
JUST LOOK AT HOW THE MEDIA SIX
WEEKS AFTER THE ELECTION HAS
CHANGED ITS TUNE ON THIS
CONSPIRACY THEORY INVOLVING
BIDEN’S SON.
REMEMBER THIS OCTOBER 19TH
HEADLINE FROM POLITICO SAYING
THAT THE HUNTER BIDEN STORY IS
MERELY RUSSIAN DISINFORMATION
ACCORDING TO DOZENS OF FORMER
INTEL OFFICIALS?
POLITICO NOW SAYS THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT’S INTEREST COVERED
MORE THAN TAXES.
THEN IT WAS NBC’S PATHETIC
MISDIRECTION.
HOW FAKE PERSONA LISA GROUNDWORK
FOR HUNTER BIDEN CONSPIRACY
DAILY SPIRIT OF THIS IS THEIR
HEADLINE TODAY, HUNTER BIDEN’S
TAX INCREASE FOCUSED ON CHINESE
STUDENTS.
WE SHOULDN’T FORGET THAT MAJOR
ASSIST TWITTER AND FACEBOOK GAVE
THE CAMPAIGN BY BLOCKING ANY
SHARING OF THAT POST EXCLUSIVE
ON HUNTER.
YOU HAVE TO HAND IT TO THESE
PEOPLE, THEY PLAY FOR KEEPS.
ETHICS AND TRUTH BE.
THEY COULDN’T RISK ANY NEGATIVE
STORY ON BIDEN GETTING ANY
TRACTION ON AND OCTOBER.
THEY LIED, AND THEY COVERED IT
UP.
THEY MALIGN THE REAL REPORTERS
ARE DOING THEIR JOB, AND THEY
LEFT AMERICAN VOTERS IN THE DARK
TO PROTECT THEIR FEEBLE
CANDIDATE.
NOW, THEY EXPECT US TO SEE THEM
AS A CHECK ON THE BIDEN